I'm very consults I'm an engineer at
Udacity for nearly three years now just
a long time they've had not machine work
on some really interesting projects that
I've worked on Android it work on some
web apps we build this global code
reviewing Network and we really exciting
project lately has been like the past
four months or so ourself every part
so we tear her under project I think
this quote from each other he plans to
build an autonomous Mae Bullock played
open-source a whole design develop
charity or generosity is about education
CBS News entire goal of a lot of the
reason you're here today is because this
is a growing industry we want to be able
to I do the ten X number of engineers
that are available to join and
oftentimes it's very mark our people
especially you're interested in this
people to get into it because the
hardware is very expensive it's
difficult to access a lot of super
efficient area or hidden awaiting
companies so we want to be able to open
source as much as possible to make you
successful in a degree and one ways
we're doing that is through a series of
challenges we want to encourage your
community around helping us build an
open-source self-driving car and you see
a lot of challenges are things that we
need for the actual hardware nickel we
could you look at challenge one it's a
3d model we need a way of mounting our
cameras in we had a students that had
three cats field about this Jarrid multi
printed we have open source design if
you look at challenge two and three
they're interesting approach John Susan
usually approach to steering which
Mackel tell you a little bit more about
it's in the rules from that the ring is
also again a low-cost way of us
and I think some of the result has been
really promising despite the challenge
on being completed and it's a cool way
that students can collaborate and work
together and try to keen on these
specific topics we break them there's
prizes awarded there's a lot of
incentive for students to join in and
contribute to move to our project and of
course at the end of it you know hide
anything away everything is distributed
you can see the results and it's great
seen students contribute and build to
these projects and I'm always impressed
by say what we're great together
it's very soon so in order to be
successful in the challenges you need
access to data and often a lot of data
and so a lot of you think about there's
not a lot of open source self-driving
car datasets they're often very large
like if you think of our vehicle
if you collect consume the total amount
of sensors we have roughly three
gigabytes a minute that we collect I
press for months it's 300 megabytes
minute but still it adds up quite a lot
we also have everything available in
open formats which is important you'll
see a lot of times people don't
distribute these because they're
difficult to collect
I mean I've everything available in
variable bin format which is great and
so some of their goals from the data
that we've been polishing which is lidar
it's every sensor available it's
multiple cameras to see those it ends up
you quite a lot we have over 12 hours of
driving data and this is not our
starting point we're continually on into
this so hopefully by the time you finish
your degree will have significantly more
but we've had a great reception - thanks
Esther publish we've been able to track
over
four hundred terabytes downloaded by
students and people as interested in
self driving car community so what
things were announced we say is the
release of Indiana Tech Data and you'll
see Lee on the internet you can find
there's an Titus x4 for signs for pests
minions but it's really hard to get
access to those even though they're open
you don't have to register or depressed
state a reason why you need it in our
case all this data is going to be
available it's under the MIT license it
won't be behind the wall that you got to
like get approval for and you'll learn
later on in your damn degree how
important things like the datasets are
especially if you start to take more
into machine learning into classifiers
and like houses through peaceful the
total amount is one hour of driving and
we was in that one hour we have over a
hundred fifty thousand bounty boxes
which is great that you know that were
santolina roughly two birds here so it's
a pretty impressive and it's something
we've built again with our student
community to have this qubit Nancy of
course but yeah it's really great so to
talk a little bit more about the results
from our challenges
[Music]
hi everyone my name is Mack Dickens
relatively new at Udacity with and said
that it probably X's spoken with you a
lot of slack heard a lot Balkan
challenges I come from a bit of a
different background the defense
industry alone stuff that flies drones
that kind of thing and I come on Udacity
as a self pregnant her engineer as well
as helping the open source development
effort of the car itself as opposed to
instead water systems engineering type
things or for hardware which is always
always really fun I'm here to talk about
that ever said what the challenges are
and what their real purpose is what I'm
doing and to go into that and it's
really about overall the democratization
of the code and the hardware behind
building a self-driving car and while
some of that is allowing you know
everyone access to the resources of the
actual vehicle itself a lot of that a
lot of the main thing that we're trying
to do is actually get all of you
students involved and that's put up some
pretty impressive numbers we've had over
it's much higher than 500 students but
that's what we can confirm for sure of
that I was actually contributed code to
testing and trying to validate the
self-driving car we've had over 200
neural networks that are trying to steer
the vehicle six Android apps to allow
humans to really intuitively interact
with the car itself and ten camera
mounts for students you know that was
our first challenge to just get out
there and make something freely
available to anyone who wants to put one
of these types of things together
someone who wants to start a company or
get employed at a company so that you
have you know access and ability to work
with with these types of things so going
directly into the challenge and the idea
of democratizing access to self-driving
car hardware a lot of the main theme is
moving away from really expensive
sensors like lidar
and which also kind of come with really
expensive datasets that you have to
build so you can have lighter but to
localize yourself to it you have to have
a ton of maps and it's very difficult to
build these maps and put them together
so we're trying to move away from that
give the power to more on the software
and on cheap camera the sight of cameras
and for this first challenge it was
really focused on using deep learning
and camera to build an end-to-end
steering solution
so what that means is essentially you
get a image frame you put it through a
neural network and out comes just a
steering angle and you can see up here
there's actually a little indication of
what this particular student submitted
neural network is estimating to be able
to drive the car around these lanes and
this isn't really new there's been you
know kind of forays into this type of
software since the late 80s of using a
neural network to drive car but it's
seen a recent resurgence partially due
to the expensive lidar but also due to
the fact that convolutional neural
networks can learn their own set of
features so human software programmers
don't necessarily have to learn what a
lane line is or how to program it you're
able to just put a ton of data at the
problem and they'll let the car learn
how to drive itself so that's cool but
you also kind of think about some of the
issues that come with that and some of
the things that use students and if you
haven't yet you'll learn how to address
the issue of well how is the car going
to recover if it goes out of the lane
because you know we're not driving
around San Francisco going into the
other Lane and trying to make mistakes
we're showing the car how to correctly
drive so that brought us into moving
into data augmentation setting up a
camera array on the inside of the
vehicle as well as a simulator that
actually allows the car to make its own
mistakes accumulate its own error we can
rotate pitch the image if you saw with
youssef outside showing how that
actually works and allows students and
yourselves the tools to download and on
your own build these algorithms that can
actually test whether or not you can
drive a car without necessarily having
to have physical access to the car so
that's another aspect of how challenge
two has really brought something that's
really big and complicated and deep
learning and giving it to the ability of
anyone to get up and start and to get
moving on actually some creating these
solutions kind of in that same vein
brings us into challenge three of moving
away from sensors and going to cameras
away from lidar we're looking at image
based localization and the point of that
is again taking an image frame from a
camera and figuring out where you are in
the real world instead of using
something like lidar that's very
expensive and tough to get and allows
you to actually figure
out where you are the cool thing about
this and what I'm really excited about
and what a lot of us that Udacity are
really excited about is the large
multitude of different approaches that
we've seen students take to this we
decided to be less prescriptive with
this challenge we had kind of an idea of
how we knew it could work but we wanted
to see what everyone could come up with
and we've seen everything from structure
for motion approaches to things like
this which is actually using deep
learning to estimate the distance
travelled by the car in each frame and
creating a bold probabilistic roadmap
and everything to more like image
matching type stuff which is what we
expected but it's really cool because
we're getting to see everyone's
different background like every single
person here has a different background
they're able to bring all these
different aspects that isn't necessarily
the traditional robotics approach to
building a self-driving car and that's
one of the cool really powerful concepts
I think of this program in general and
and what we're able to do this is an
example of a student submission that
uses the traditional image matching type
stuff and while you might think you know
it might be kind of confusing as to you
know isn't you know as a lower res image
like this have a high enough enough data
to actually match to figure out where
you are at the same kind of granularity
is lighter and and we're actually seen
from people just like yourselves that
that is possible and that you guys can
create some some really really cool
software and well a lot of this might
seem kind of intimidating and for those
of you who started haven't started the
nano degree yet it might seem like I
don't know how to do this at all but a
lot of these people didn't know that
either and we're really excited to see
as you begin learning these concepts as
you get exposed to these what ideas that
you can bring to the table and what
ideas you guys are actually able to come
up and start submitting to challenges
because while we've already had these
two there's gonna be a lot more and
they're gonna get bigger and we want to
see what ideas you guys bring to the
table and that first class like Chiron
is the same with those you know 300
people we want to see what you guys can
contribute to the open source car and
this effort in general Thanks appreciate
it
[Applause]